políticas que puede hacer el nuevo
Primer Ministro de Reino Unido falta que
jure en el cargo por supuesto pero
digamos que en el papel ya es el Primer
Ministro de Reino Unido Richi es una que
tiene que hacer para calmar digamos los
mercados para tratar de llevar una
estabilidad política dentro de su país y
también como llega y como recibe Europa
como recibiría Europa este nombramiento
de registro es una como Primer Ministro
de Reino Unido Carmen
Hola Muchas gracias Mira yo creo que sí
Este primer anuncio de su primer
presupuesto de sus líneas de gobierno
van a ser claves lo que tanto los
mercados como la población acá están
esperando realmente es claridad y
estabilidad porque las últimas semanas
las últimas seis semanas han sido
realmente de Caos una sensación de Caos
total algo viene a Inglaterra no no no
es algo a lo que la gente está
acostumbrado y por lo tanto se le va a
pedir al Primer Ministro que ponga orden
en la casa ahora el desafío que tiene
que es muy grande es cómo se consigue
crecimiento por ejemplo a nivel
económico sin aumentar el gasto social
en el momento que estamos con crisis
múltiples energética política económica
con un 10% de inflación para satisfacer
la demanda de su población que es en
este momento está lo va a pasar mal se
viene el invierno se vienen las cuentas
energética que van a hacer van a estar
muy altas y problemas múltiples tanto
como para la educación la salud etcétera
Carmen también recordemos que fue el
propio partido conservador que presionó
a Alice para que dejara su cargo a un
lado para que renunciara como la primera
ministra británica evidentemente el
mismo partido conservador eligió en este
momento a richizuna ahora la pregunta es
van a dejar gobernar a Richi zonas más
de 44 días como lo hicieron con Penny
Morgan evidentemente todo parece indicar
que sí perdón con Collins evidentemente
todo parece indicar que sí para tratar
de calmar un poco los ánimos no Y
también toda la economía de Reino Unido
pero digamos Cómo están las cosas dentro
del propio partido conservador
yo creo que dentro del partido
conservador se ve a richa es una como la
única opción la única opción de seriedad
la única opción de alguien preparado que
tiene por lo menos una noción Clara de
lo que se necesita hacer a nivel
económico ahora con usted de acuerdo no
esté de acuerdo con las políticas que él
vaya a llevar adelante es una persona
preparada y en ese aspecto va a entregar
por lo menos al sector económico una una
tranquilidad muy grande el partido sin
embargo sigue con una guerra civil
bastante importante por dentro los
grupos de extrema derecha el european
resorte hasta hoy día se suponía digamos
a darle el apoyo que fuera él como a
Morgan
siguen siendo grupos con mucha
influencia dentro del partido Aunque ha
disminuido porque todas las las
estadísticas indican de que el partido
ha perdido apoyo en el entre la
ciudadanía de modo vertiginoso es decir
su propio zinc están hoy día que se
llama onward Up
estaba publicando hoy día una serie de
láminas donde explicaban de que si no
aumentan rápidamente una política
intervencionista económica y mantienen
ciertas políticas de orden social más
bien conservador Como por ejemplo
políticas antimigración y también anti
por ejemplo lo que serían los temas
trans o temas valóricos
el partido digamos se podría dividir y
quebrar en dos Entonces
no sé cómo va a navegar todas todas esos
parámetros el Primer Ministro pero yo
creo que es alguien que viene observando
todo lo que pasa hace rato no es alguien
que va a improvisar y yo creo que nos
podemos esperar a algunos anuncios
bastante drásticos unas elecciones
generales digamos fuera del panorama por
el momento a menos que las cosas se le
complican evidentemente a Richi zonas
sí no quiero quiero hablar de una
posibilidad de A lo mejor unas
elecciones generales como también lo
estábamos conversando con nuestra con
nuestra corresponsal Luisa Pulido que
más del 50% de la población elegiría
evidentemente a los laboristas por este
todo por este caos políticos que también
como lo conversábamos con analistas
anteriores digamos que pudo haber
comenzado con David Cameron cuando hizo
este referendo del brexit para la salida
de Reino Unido de la Unión Europea luego
cuando se materializó que todavía no hay
unas cosas claras sobre todo con el
protocolo de Irlanda del Norte Entonces
qué tan lejos o cerca pudiéramos estar
de de unas elecciones generales cuál
sería el escenario digamos que tiene que
haber dentro del Reino Unido para que
esta posibilidad sea sea
efectivamente interesante lo que nombras
tú el protocolo de Irlanda del Norte es
súper importante porque el libro piel lo
único que quiere es terminar con brexits
no a la dura como lo venían haciendo y
la presión que tenía orden como ozuna
que esta mañana era comprometerse a usar
los actos de parlamento que significa
que el parlamento y la casa de los
comunes puede
tomar una decisión sin sin pasar por los
lords no y llevar a cabo Por ende este
protocolo de Irlanda del Norte
eso haría que que la derecha dura
digamos se fortalezca dentro del partido
pero al mismo tiempo no es
necesariamente la que la el electorado
quiere porque lo que está sucediendo es
que en realidad el votante Tori Parece
ser mucho más sentrista mucho más
moderado y eso le quitaría Mucho peso
asunen dentro de su propio partido con
el otro con la otra la Entonces es un
acto de equilibrio el que tiene que ser
el Primer Ministro y esto podría llevar
atenciones tan grandes que sí se podría
llamar a elecciones
generales rápidamente si es que por
ejemplo él no no hace lo que quiere está
la dura y decide dejar poner el tema del
protocolo Irlanda del Norte eso sería
por ejemplo un escenario en términos
económicos
mayor gasto social etcétera etcétera
También podríamos crear malestar entre
ciertos grupos del partido conservador
Entonces no no se sabe exactamente qué
podría hacer lo caer pero existen muchos
elementos que sí podrían Entonces si
estamos frente a la primera vez desde el
97 que el partido laborista está tan
fuerte en las encuestas hay más de 38
puntos creo de diferencia en este
momento y
cualquier error va a hacer caer este
gobierno o sea Esa es la fragilidad con
la que está trabajando regizunak por lo
tanto es un acto valentía pasar a ser
Primer Ministro en este momento en este
momento actual que vive que vive Reino
Unido pero digamos también Carmen en el
partido laborista que otras opciones
tienen más allá de hacer posiciones
evidentemente dentro de la cámara de los
comunes no tienen otra opción más allá
para acercarse más más al gobierno no
para presionar más digamos este está
esta estabilidad que puede alcanzar el
partido conservador con la elección de
Richard o también digamos el partido de
ahorita en este momento que Ojalá sea
así piense en el pueblo y diga pues
vamos a esperar a ver qué hace Richie
sunak para estabilizar las cosas porque
al final los que están sufriendo Ahora
son los británicos con Los Altos costos
de la energía sobre todo de cara al
invierno cuando también siempre lo
hablamos con nuestra corresponsal Luisa
Pulido la gente pues va a tener que
elegir dentro de poco Digamos si comer o
calentarse
Sí eso es totalmente cierto yo creo que
el partido laborista ha estado haciendo
un juego de ajedrez muy inteligente si
uno observa ahora con con un poquito de
distancia y es que ha dejado a los
conservadores cometer los errores solos
pero también y la semana pasada se
hicieron casi en parte caer atrás
forzaron un voto sobre el tema de
fracking No
eso la extracción
en el norte de Inglaterra
de modo táctico porque al forzar ese
voto en la cámara de los comunes dejaron
en claro frente a toda la población Cuál
era la posición por ejemplo del partido
de pasar a llevar sus promesas del 2019
yo creo que va a ser un el juego del
partido laborista en este momento va a
ser eso dejar que se cometan errores de
modo espontáneo pero al mismo tiempo
también provocar en ciertos temas por
ejemplo podríamos hablar algo
relacionado a gastos salud podríamos
leer temas de inmigración podrían ir de
modo muy sutilmente poniendo trabas al
gobierno para obligarlo a pronunciarse
sobre ciertas políticas que lo que van a
incomodar al electorado Y esa Esa es la
táctica que hasta ahora les ha
funcionado muy bien y es un ejercicio de
paciencia en el fondo dejar que este
gobierno caiga
qué va a pasar con Penny Morgan va a
seguir siendo la líder de los
conservadores dentro de la cámara de los
comunes todavía digamos o puede seguir
siendo una persona fuerte dentro del
partido conservador recordemos también
que se hablaba de que es muy apoyado
dentro de las bases duras del partido
conservador va a seguir teniendo su peso
fuerte en este partido
yo creo que sí De todas maneras incluso
cuando los los
miembros de parlamento pasan a lo que se
llaman los backventures no que se
sientan más atrás que no son parte de
gobierno
se siguen teniendo una influencia muy
grande y entonces da lo mismo en
realidad donde esté sentada es un
personaje con mucho poder con mucho
arrastre y por algo llegó hasta la
nominación Ahora hasta donde llegó
y sí yo por lo menos la veo jugando un
rol importante ahora bien No creo
no no sé exactamente hasta cuando no
escucha bastante chisme interno de los
partidos así si es una realmente la va a
incorporar al gobierno que podría ser
una tácticamente interesante un modo de
controlar a ese sector incorporandolo
dentro del gobierno entonces hay que ver
cómo es una gravedad eso yo creo que es
una aquel que va realmente poner en
orden en la casa y tiene ese control
porque hoy día lo que pasó fue que
realmente lo convirtieron en líder de su
partido él va a tomar decisiones él va a
decidir quién se sienta dónde y en qué
lugar porque necesita tener un liderazgo
Ahora más que nunca firme si no puede
ser desastroso claro Carmen También
tenemos en nuestra conversación o
conectada a nuestra corresponsal en
Londres a Pulido que quisiera incorporar
y y Luisa Yo no sé que puede pasar
también con listos completamente ya
fuera de la escena política de Reino
Unido las primeras ministra más breve de
ese país y también bueno estás
escuchando nuestra conversación con
Carmen evidentemente cualquier pregunta
que le quieras hacer esta bienvenida a
Luis
Gracias Raúl definitivamente listas está
en las últimas horas en el gobierno en
down Street mañana muy probablemente irá
a visitar al Rey Carlos tercero para
presentar oficialmente su renuncia como
primera ministra y posteriormente
entonces richis unac ingresará
probablemente al palacio de wackenna m
aquí en el centro de Londres y entonces
el Rey Carlos III le preguntará a Richi
snack le pedirá que forme Un gobierno en
su nombre y entonces iniciará el
gobierno de Richi szunak Y por supuesto
la gran pregunta es qué va a suceder con
listas después de esta situación tan
compleja he leído en los periódicos
cercanos al partido conservador que las
últimas horas de listras antes de que
fuera forzada a renunciar fueron muy
difíciles a nivel personal y que de
hecho cuando Ella termina
curso que vimos aquí en France 24 en el
que renuncia ella reingresa a Downey
Street su cara era de completo alivio
porque había tenido seis semanas de
pesadillas Así que seguramente listas
seguirá como diputada pero seguramente
necesitará unas vacaciones Raúl después
de semejante crisis y la complejidad que
tuvo que vivir como persona será bien
compleja pero no hay certeza de si por
ejemplo seguirá como Teresa May como
diputada como Back bencher o
definitivamente renunciará no sabemos no
se conoce por supuesto Cuáles son los
planes futuros del issstras salvo que
está terminando su gobierno las últimas
horas que estará como inquilina de
Downey Street Así es Carmen si también
quiero saber su opinión sobre el futuro
de la saliente listroso también los
británicos Se caracterizan por ser muy
no y muy Francos digamos y tener una una
libertad de prensa bien crítica también
contra los líderes recordemos obviamente
lo de la lechuga que estaba una lechuga
con una foto de litros para ver quién
dura más finalmente pues ganó la lechuga
con listos entonces realmente fue fue
bien duro me imagino también como lo
dice Luisa para para Liz Rose no y y que
va a ser de Su futuro
Sí tú lo has dicho eh la prensa inglesa
no no digamos tiene una lengua no
perdona no perdona nada no perdona nada
les escapa y es algo la verdad hay que
tener mucha valentía para tomar un cargo
acá porque el nivel de escrutinio al que
se al que se
ponen ellos mismos es muy alto el
ilustración creo que ahora va le va a
pasar algo como Cameron o también lo que
hizo una Teresa May desaparecen durante
un buen tiempo del espacio público
porque yo creo que tiene un desgaste a
nivel emocional muy grande Todo lo que
sucede y generalmente ocupan cargos
generalmente se sale no hay no hay
realmente un espacio para reincorporarse
como como en ti directamente Es raro
bueno Teresa y lo hizo pero pero yo creo
que hay un momento en que se salen un
poquito de la luz no de los focos de la
prensa
Así que Ojalá
tengamos más claridad ahora muy
interesante también parece ser no sé si
se han dado cuenta pero cada vez que se
eligió a un nuevo una nueva un nuevo
Primer Ministro
sin elecciones tendió a ser una persona
a la cual se le traspasa mucha
responsabilidad del caso Teresa May tras
lo que pasó con Cameron lo de listros
tras lo que pasó con Johnson y ahora a
Richie sunak con lo que pasó con con sus
antecesores entonces son son puestos que
son aún más difíciles que cuando son
elegidos con un mandato directo lo de
Teresa May fue bien fuerte incluso lo
vimos llorando en varias oportunidades o
por digamos la presión también dentro de
la cámara de los comunes que manejaban
estábamos hablando evidentemente de las
críticas y la y la presión de de la
prensa digamos dentro del Reino Unido
pero también es que eso se vive dentro
del parlamento abucheos incluso gritos
que pasan cuando
luego están de acuerdo con lo que dice
un parlamentario o un Primer Ministro
qué tan respetado Carmen ese rishizuna
dentro de la cámara de los comunes
podemos ver digamos estos escenarios Por
así decirlo que estamos acostumbrados a
ver dentro estas discusiones acaloradas
dentro de de Westminster
Sí bueno el que te refiere que es una
tradición no del parlamento inglés en el
que hoy levantan la voz y es un modo de
intimidar un poquito a la a la
contraparte
es un es una es una práctica común pero
que además yo creo es llevada un poquito
al extremo cuando se producen estos
Estos espacios de Caos de todas maneras
Richie sunak por mucho respeto que se le
tenga a su preparación a su capacidad
técnica etcétera se va a tener que
también presentar ante la causa
commons
con un poquito de humedad porque al
final de cuentas él era la mano derecha
bajo el gobierno de Boris Johnson a él
también se le encararon una serie de
problemas con el sistema económico por
medidas que él tomó y ahora vuelve como
Primer Ministro iba a tener que ganarse
la confianza digamos tanto de su bancada
aunque con la oposición cero chance de
que lo apoyen así que
va a ser un contexto muy duro y yo creo
que he aquí vamos a ver mucho en la
cámara de los comunes Claro claro Carmen
y además también hay que recordar que
rissis 1 También estuvo involucrado en
todo este escándalo que le costó también
el puesto a Primer Ministro Boris
Johnson hablamos del Party fue uno de
los invitados a esta fiestas dentro de
de Downey Street no Entonces como lo
dices no lo va a tener fácil con la
oposición Y pues también resiste una
tiene rabo de paja como quien dice
Sí de todas maneras cuando uno ya está
está un poco incriminado por decirlo de
algún modo eso no se lo van a dejar
pasar tan fácilmente La yo estoy segura
que la oposición se va a encargar de
sacarse lo que era muy rápidamente y le
va a tocar al partido ponerse duro en
defensa de él porque si no va a ser un
piso muy muy frágil sobre el que va a
caminar
Luisa quiero volver con ustedes para
también preguntarles y también será el
fin digamos o político de alguna manera
en el Spotlight de Boris Johnson
hablamos de listros que seguramente A lo
mejor lo va a hacer pero Boris Johnson
va a seguir siendo una figura fuerte
dentro de los conservadores dentro de
digamos de círculos cercanos de Racing
sunat porque recordemos que es una fue
ministro de economía de Johnson y y
amigo íntimo para estar en esta fiesta
si Richi es una estuvo en la fiesta de
cumpleaños de Boris Johnson y por eso
fue multado pero lo cierto Es que tienen
diferencias absolutas de hecho cuando
por Johnson fue forzado a renunciar fue
por un complot de Richie sunat podría
decirse con el Entonces otro ministro de
salud
y entonces empezaron las cascadas de
renuncias y lo que se sabe es que Boris
Johnson estaba absolutamente furioso por
este complot de Richi es una que
iniciado por Richard y les pidió a los
miembros del gabinete que no votaran por
Richie y lo hicieran por listras y de
hecho Penny Morgan y richichina que eran
los favoritos Pero el día que concluyó
la votación finalmente fue elegida
listas y Richi es una como los
finalistas Entonces eso nos muestra las
diferencias profundas que tienen los dos
yo de verdad no creo que Richi es una
vaya a recibir mayores consejos de Boris
Johnson Quién es a nivel nacional una
figura absolutamente desprestigiada por
todas esas crisis políticas de las que
fue protagonista estuvo en los últimos
meses de su gobierno defendiéndose y no
gobernando que es la gran crítica que se
ha hecho recientemente y sobre todo por
esa compleja relación con la verdad que
tiene el ex Primer Ministro de hecho en
su carta de anuncio ayer de candidatura
Richi es una ha dicho que liderará con
altos estándares excéticos y eso sin
duda era un mensaje clarísimo para Boris
Johnson sobre el futuro de Boris Johnson
bueno él lo dejó clarísimo ha dicho que
tendrá mucha posibilidad de regresar al
lado de las elecciones generales en 2024
ha dicho que tiene todavía muchísimo que
aportar al partido conservador y al país
pero lo cierto es que escu bien no se
encuentran los votos que volvés Johnson
ha dicho en esa carta muy a su Estilo
que tenía y de hecho decía que podría
estar este mismo viernes gobernando
nuevamente desde down Street pero lo
cierto Es que no se ha presentado y se
dice muy internamente aquí por los
expertos y quienes han sido testigos de
excepción de la política británica por
años es que Boris Johnson son
Simplemente no tenía los votos para
presentarse Porque si se hubiera
presentado hubiera tenido la posibilidad
seria de ser reelegido con
con la posibilidad de que pudiera sido
destituido hubiera tenido que ser
forzado a renunciar nuevamente porque el
parlamento británico lo está
investigando sobre si mintió o no
deliberadamente sobre el partygate Así
que para responder concretamente a tu
pregunta tendremos Boris Johnson por
mucho mucho tiempo